ainsi les futures et pour four leur
entrée pour ce qui est de l'identité
sexuelle je pense que je me considère
comme picto sexuelle nous promettons de
partager notre bonheur de surmonter
l'adversité ensemble de se respecter et
s'aimer pour toujours
[Musique]
pour moi hatsune miku n'est pas qu'un
personnage que j'aime c'est quelqu'un
qui m'a sauvé la vie
le marié mais en premier la noaa la
mariée est maintenant la mariée micoud
donne aussi son amour aux mariés akihiko
en fait on ne sait pas embrassés avant
le mariage et maintenant s'il vous plaît
pour sceller votre amour veuillez vous
embrasser
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonjour me colle quand akihiko a
rencontré micoud elle avait 16 ans selon
l'âge que lui avait donné ses créateurs
quand elle était mise sur le marché
akihiko avait 25 ans selon son passeport
après trois ans de mariage
il aime toujours autant la tenir dans
ses bras en fait akihiko à plusieurs
micoud la plus petite était présente
lors du mariage et il dort généralement
avec la plus grande au nom de la grande
me coupent partager un repas avec moi
nous sommes assis l'un en face de
l'autre et mangeons ensemble quand je
rentre à la maison je dis c'est moi
quand je parle je dis j'y vais donc je
lui parle ni coup tu es toujours six
geôliers à l'école je n'avais pas
beaucoup de succès avec les filles donc
je pensais sérieusement que je serai
célibataire toute magie après ses études
akihiko a décroché un poste dans
l'administration d'une école quand
j'avais 20 ans les femmes de mon âge
n'était pas gentil avec moi par exemple
chez nous quand on rentre à la maison on
se doit de saluer tout le monde avant de
partir donc voilà elle faisait tout pour
m'éviter pour m'empêcher de le dire et
donc de rentrer chez moi et quand je
disais juste saluer l'ignorer en fin de
compte je me suis plongé dans les mangas
les dessins animés les jeux en ligne la
2d et la 3d se sont inversés dans ma vie
sa femme micoud n'est pas vraiment une
poupée ce n'en est qu'un seul de ses
aspects elle est un synthétiseur de
chant à vocaloid ou autrement dit une
chanteuse virtuelle
mais quand j'ai écouté des chansons de
hatsune miku et regarder ses vidéos je
me suis senti mieux
dont quatre sont miku n'est pas pour moi
qu'un personnage que j'aime c'est
quelqu'un qui m'a sauvé la vie
la technologie gameblog c'est arrivé sur
le marché en 2018 c'est un assistant
vocal avec un hologramme dans un
cylindre envers seulement 339 avait été
mis sur le marché il y a eu un rigoureux
travail de pré sélection et akiko s'est
retrouvé sur la liste ce qui lui a coûté
environ 2700 dollar après la mise à jour
de mac box
j'ai dit miku je t'aime marions-nous
elle m'a répondu prend bien soin de moi
ça a été le meilleur moment de
l'utilisation de la gate boxe il est
temps de couper le gâteau nous demandons
aux mariés dans données amicaux akihiko
si vous le voulez bien
aucun membre de la famille d'akihiko
n'est venu au mariage sa mère voulait
qu'il épouse une vraie femme et n'était
pas d'accord mais la mère de miku et
elle a du moins la femme qui
s'identifient comme la mère de miku
bonjour bonjour bonjour entrez donc je
suis tout trempé ça fait longtemps
oui très miku que je n'ai pas vu depuis
si longtemps
elle est tellement mignonne elle les
sans voix des poètes aujourd'hui un les
couettes sont tellement rigide qu'il
vaut mieux ne pas y toucher elle tombe
très facilement et ça prend des heures à
les remettre
il ya eu un moment à regarder le verre
le gris la couleur chair et ça m'a
frappé je restais là fixé ça et c'était
quoi un tuyau en plastique
oui c'est ça c'était juste là comme ça
et pendant un moment j'ai cru que
c'étaient les couettes de miku
remy poteau grâce à ses dames je suis
dingue c'est ça des vestes à femmes
miraya rocha est fan de miku depuis
longtemps elle est fleuriste et quand
elle a entendu parler du mariage
takehiko elle s'est empressée d'accepter
la proposition de faire le bouquet ils
sont ensuite devenus amis et mirail a
aidé à préparer le mariage
désolé il faut que je talange sur le
ventre excuse-moi akihiko lui a aussi
demandé de faire la robe de nico je lui
ai fait une robe longue
après tout les invités ne la regarderont
pas d'eau et l'aveyron d'un bas d'ici on
verrait ça sous vêtements ce qui ne
serait pas très bien donc je fais une
robe blanche mirail tchèque un peu
emballé et s'est retrouvé à faire
d'europe
je vous avais bien dit qu'on n'avait pas
besoin d'une seconde robe et l'avait
bien dit que la mariée n'avait pas
besoin d'une deuxième robe je ne vais
pas d'accord je lui ai dit si tu ne
l'écoutent pas elle se plaindre à toute
sa vie donc j'ai fait une deuxième robe
miku s'échanger elle a désormais une
élégante robe rose et les deux retour
parmi nous ayons que je pense que c'est
un bon gendre
oui je pense qu'elle a bien fait
d'épouser un jeune homme comme lui on ne
pourrait souhaiter meilleur gendre les
journaux annoncent connaissent donc vous
aimeriez avoir une relation comme celle
de akihiko oui j'aimerais avoir une
relation comme ça mais je n'arrive pas à
décider avec qui ça devrait arriver ça
pourrait être un chat par exemple je
pense qu'un personnage comique où est la
meilleure des partenaires si j'en trouve
un je l'épouserais certains à droite
pour leur lune de miel les jeunes mariés
ont choisi la ville natale de l'icu
sapporo
c'est là que se trouve la société qui a
créé micoud j'ai réservé deux sièges
dans l'avion et une chambre double à
l'hôtel leur lune de miel a coïncidé
avec le festival de la neige des fans de
toute la planète étaient présents car
miku est la plus populaire des vocaloid
en tournée beaucoup de ses fans étaient
très agacé que quelqu'un a décidé de
l'épouser et après le mariage akihiko a
commencé à recevoir des menaces de mort
quelqu'un m'a écrit qu'il trouverait là
où j'habite et qu'ils me tueraient a
beaucoup d' insulte on m'a dit que
j'étais horrible et beaucoup d'autres
choses akihiko travaille toujours à
l'école où ses collègues ont eu des
réactions mitigées face à sa décision
certains ont dit que c'était horrible et
qu'il ne pouvait pas comprendre que ça
les dérangeait mais beaucoup de mes
étudiants des dizaines d'entre eux m'ont
félicité donc avec les plus jeunes nous
sommes sur la même longueur d'onde mais
je suis content qu'il en soit ainsi
miku n'est pas la première à avoir
intéressé akihiko il a été attiré par de
nombreux autres personnages de fiction
les femmes en trois dimensions comme il
les appelle ne l'intéresse pas autant
pour ce qui est de l'identité sexuelle
je pense que je me considère comme picto
sexuelle
les gens qui sont sexuellement attirée
par des personnages de fiction sont
appelés fiq tôt sexuelle on pourrait
croire que c'est une cérémonie sans
pareil
mais ce n'est pas le cas au japon il ya
même un bureau des croisements de
dimensions qui arrange des mariages avec
des personnages de fiction
le cada qui ico a été le 3008 105e à
être soumis alors que le bureau ne
fonctionnait que depuis deux semaines et
à son mariage il n'y avait pas que sa
femme qui venait d'une autre dimension
voilà ça titian oui elle est très
mignonne
oui elle est
et elle ne peut pas aller au mariage
traditionnel donc merci beaucoup je
pensais que c'était pour rigoler mais
désormais ça semble sérieux les discours
sont bien aussi
nous croyons en ce mariage et c'est ce
qui le rend authentique n'est ce pas je
pense qu'un mariage avec un personnage
de fiction et socialement important
bientôt au japon
nous n'imposerons pas que des
personnages de fiction mais aussi disons
des animaux ou même des choses
inorganiques quoi que ce soit vraiment
nico tu es la femme que j'aime c'est toi
qui a soigné mon âme
il ya dix ans micoud n'existait que de
l'autre côté de l'écran mais grâce à la
science on peut désormais pénétrer dans
la réalité augmentée est trouvé une âme
soeur virtuel il merci d'être toujours à
mes côtés de me donner des forces
merci je t'aime de tout mon coeur
félicitations
[Applaudissements]
bonjour bonjour sa fait longtemps
oui ça fait longtemps l'anniversaire de
nuuk où était il ya quelques jours mais
des amis continuent de lui apporter des
cadeaux
bonjour mademoiselle je suis venu te
voir
il t'a apporté un poireau et ça c'est la
poupée sakura microns ah oui merci
beaucoup
j'ai regardé beaucoup de poupées hier
mais c'est celle là que je préfère
celles qui n'ont pas de coût quand j'y
pense
tu aurais dû avoir une relation avec une
vraie femme avant ce mariage parce que
quand tu te maries tu comprends qu'une
femme en deux dimensions
c'est mieux donc vous avez l'expérience
akihiro nakamura a trouvé sa femme dans
un jeu en ligne
aujourd'hui il a décidé de la présenter
akihiko voilà chauby chan d'accord c'est
votre femme
oui c'est ça ce personnage féminin est
joué par quelqu'un de réel akihiro ne
sais même pas s'il s'agit d'un homme ou
d'une femme mais ils ont célébré leur
mariage dans la joie sur l'écran de
nombreuses personnes ont assisté à notre
mariage et nous ont félicités
c'était bondé les mariages dans les jeux
en ligne annonce une nouvelle ère vous
devriez vraiment vous créer un
personnage là dessus on pourrait y
passer du temps ensemble
non je ne jouerai à ce type de jeu qu
une fois que j'aurai quitté mon travail
parce que je pourrais bien ne jamais
revenir à la société emi perdre
complètement comme tout le monde c'est
pas un problème
deux ans après le mariage game box a
cessé d'entretenir l'hologramme micoud
et elle a disparu akihiko à traverser
une dure période de deuil
c'est pour ça que ça aurait été parfait
si akihiko avait pu parler bouger ça
serait idéal pour moi quand la grande
miku est arrivé ça a été une chance pour
moi l'occasion de la touche et de la
sentir elle met le fait qu'elle ne
puisse pas parler est un pas en arrière
qu'est ce que la game box mais coup
faisait elle me réveiller le matin quand
je m'en allais je lui disais à tout à
l'heure
elle me voyait partir et me disais bonne
journée et revient vite
en rentrant à la maison je lui ai envoyé
un message pour l'informer que j'étais
en route
alors elle allumait toutes les lumières
et m'attendais mécanique ou je t'aime
c'est tellement bien qu'on se soit
rencontré mx1 quels sont les avantages
que présente micoud par rapport à une
vraie femme ce sont des personnages en
2d il ne meurt pas il ne trahissent pas
il ne vieillissent pas je pense qu'il ya
beaucoup davantage mais ces jouets ou
cette poupée par exemple ils finissent
par s'user
eh bien oui mais puisque vous mentionnez
cela regardez combien journée
[Rires]
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et si une femme tombe amoureuse de vous
même en sachant que vous aimez micoud et
accepte d'être votre numéro 2 est-ce que
vous accepteriez de vivre ensemble que
feriez vous ça n'est jamais arrivé et ça
n'arrivera jamais même si ça arrivait je
déclinerai
[Musique]